So, our next question is to Dr. Zakir
Naik, and this is about the topic of
similar on the concept of disunity, and
this is what we see as oppression that
we see today. So, now
everyone around the world, Muslims and
non-Muslims alike, they look at the
oppression today, so much rampant
injustice, and they feel this sense of
helplessness.
What tends to happen though is that they
look into political ideologies for
solutions.
How does the Sunnah
provide a superior framework for the
social justice that protects in a way
that sometimes people tend to overlook?
The question posed that
we do agree there's oppression in the
world. A lot to the Muslim level,
non-Muslim, and we usually look up for
the solution in the political
and the present ideology. What solution
is given by the Sunnah
for protection against oppression?
As far as the Sunnah is concerned, I
would think it's not one layer of
protection.
The Sunnah gives a multiple layers
of shield against oppression.
It gives a spiritual shield.
It gives a social shield. It gives a
typical and moral shield, as well
as a physical action.
The most important shield
is the spiritual shield.
And our beloved Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said
that the dua of an oppressed person
goes directly to Allah,
and there's no one in between.
The Hadith in Muttafaq Alaihi in Bukhari
and Muslim is mentioned in Sahih
Bukhari, Hadith number 2448,
and in Sahih Muslim, Hadith number 19,
that our beloved Prophet said that
beware
of the dua
of the person who's oppressed. It is
carried above the clouds,
and Allah says, "By my might
and my majesty,
the help is
near you."
Allah directly replies that I'm going to
help you.
And irrespective whether the oppressed
person
is a Muslim or a non-Muslim,
whether he's a sinner or not a sinner.
If he's a oppressed person, even if he's
a non-Muslim, even if he's a sinner,
Allah hears the dua.
And what did the Prophet recommend?
The Prophet recommended for an oppressed
person to do dua to Allah, and to do dua
that "Oh Allah,
you be my shield
against
my oppressors.
And I seek refuge
in you
from the shar
of the oppressors."
This is number one shield. I want to cut
it short. Don't want to give a lecture.
Most important shield
is no one can help you better than
Allah.
When you're oppressed, number one person
who can help you the best is Allah.
And we get guidance from Allah and his
Rasul for the second shield,
[clears throat]
that is
the social shield. And there are levels
of that.
Hadith of the Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam of Sahih
Bukhari, Hadith number 2444,
where
our Prophet said
that help another Muslim
irrespective whether he's oppressor
or he's being oppressed.
How do you do that?
If I see a Muslim is being oppressed,
I go and support him for his rights.
If I see a Muslim who is oppressing,
I stop him.
Whether your brother is oppressor or
being oppressed, you have to help both
the people.
For example, if someone is being robbed,
and if a Muslim is being robbed, I will
try and help him prevent being robbed.
If a Muslim is robbing, I will try and
prevent him from being successful in
robbing someone else.
The second level of the shield is the
Hadith
of Sahih Muslim,
Hadith number 49,
where our beloved Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, "When
you see evil,
stop it with your hand.
If you cannot stop it with the hand,
stop it with the tongue.
If you cannot stop it with the tongue,
the least you can do is curse in your
heart, and you will have the lowest
level of iman."
So, if I as a Muslim on a society level,
on a spiritual level,
the second is society level, I see a
wrong thing being done.
If Allah has given me the ability, I
stop it with my hand.
If I see someone is raping someone,
if I have the ability, I will stop it
with my hand.
If I think no, I'm not strong, I may get
killed, the least I can do is
stop it with my tongue.
Tell him you stop it, or call for help.
If you fear that also, the least you can
do is curse in your heart. On the
society level,
you have to help
the person who's being oppressed.
And the Hadith of Riyadhus Saliheen,
Hadith number 194, which says that
"Which is the best deed? The best
Jihad?" And the Prophet replied, "The
best Jihad is speaking a word of truth
against a tyrant ruler." So, if you
speak the word of truth, one word,
against a tyrant ruler,
it is Jihad.
This is on a society level.
Come to the third level of ethical and
moral,
where
it says
our beloved Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam,
he said
that when you see
any evil,
you have to stop it.
And the fourth
is the level of actions. Hadith of Ibn
Majah, 4210, that give charity. You are
the person who's being oppressed.
Give charity.
It will help you in many ways. It will
help you in washing away your sins.
So, help do charities. Your actions
also, if you're being oppressed, you
should do charity. So, these are the
levels that have been prescribed in the
Sunnah
that we can use against oppression
that's happening today in the world.
Masha Allah. Baraka Allahu Feek.
Masha Allah, it's a very interesting
perspective that you brought in, Dr.
Zakir Naik, because we've heard this
Hadith before. Maybe what we didn't see
was how the Sunnah protects it on many
different aspects, from the moral
shield, the spiritual shield, and the
society level. So, I think this is the
aspect of the wisdom of the zooming in
and zoom out, as Sheikh Haitham
mentioned, that we can understand and
appreciate the Sunnah and how it
protects against oppression on those
different levels. Masha Allah. Baraka
Allahu Feek.